- Welcome everyone to Brilliant
Minds, Bold Questions,
a five-part virtual event
series exploring questions
being addressed by some of
the world's top researchers.
Each talk pairs speakers and moderators
from across discipline
sectors in the world
to explore the question,
shaping our future.
If you're not familiar with us,
CIFAR is a Canadian
based global organization
that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most
important questions facing
science and humanity.
My name is Rachel Parker
and I'm Senior Director
of Research at CIFAR.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce to you Dan Breznitz
and Woody Powell today.
Dan is an expert on the globalization
of rapid innovation based industries
and has led pioneering research
on the distributional impact
of innovation policies.
Woody's interests focus on the processes
through which ideas and
practices are transferred
across organizations
and the role of networks
in facilitating or hindering innovation.
Today, we'll explore growth
and equity, can we have both?
Woody, I'd like to turn it over to you now
to ask the first question.
- Sure, thank you, Rachel.
Dan, thank you for your new book
on "Innovation in Real Places".
We'll talk a little bit
about what you think of is unreal places.
I have a feeling my territory
out here in California
is one such place in your mind.
But you looked at innovation
that's not focused on
Silicon Valley, or Seattle, or Schengen
but rather on opportunities
and communities
that don't normally get
considered when one thinks
about them as centres of prosperity.
Because I want to start by
asking you isn't innovation
fundamentally about breaking
rules and challenging
existing ways of doing things?
And does it always have to
have an outsider quality to it?
- Thank you, Woody.
And yes, just by your
question it is very clear
that you come from Silicon
Valley, which is slightly unreal.
No, so I would say that
unfortunately in the last few years
our debate, especially publicly
debate about innovation,
has been completely divorced from reality
and we forgot what innovation is
where is that thing
which is called invention
coming up with new ideas
for product or services.
Innovation is actually putting
that ideas into reality
in the marketplace.
And that includes all
stages from coming up
with an idea to after
service, production, assembly,
design versus the real innovation.
And if you want to see a
real innovation in action
creating widespread prosperity,
forget Silicon Valley.
Come with me to Taiwan.
Come with me to Finland.
Come with me to Germany.
Indeed, you know, unless
you really like Tesla.
And by the way, even if you like Tesla,
open it up and you'll
find out that most of it
is Bosch, a German company.
I know Allan doesn't like
that but that's the truth.
And that's where you
really have innovation.
And that through that
movement, through those stages,
through that constant and
continuous improvement, changing,
tweaking, is where
you've got real advantage
to welfare and real economic
growth and prosperity.
Just think for a moment about the millions
of engineering hours that
have been put into innovation
of how to improve the CPU,
the memory, the fibre optics,
the amount of data you
can move into fibre optics
so you and I can now talk on Zoom.
- You said a number of things
here I want to explore.
You expanded the idea of innovation
to think about invention and
every stage of production.
You also added this idea
of continuous improvement.
Those are two things that
are sort of different
than, you know, the one
big disruptive idea.
You also mentioned countries
like Taiwan, Finland,
Israel is another example
that are very diverse
on some dimensions but seem
to be places quite different
from say the traditional
centres and the tech capitals
where the gains of innovation
are shared more widely.
So what's the relationship
between this continuous
improvement at every stage
of production and being in a society
where more people benefit
from these advancements?
- Sure, so let me go back to
the places that you mentioned.
I think that one thing
that we have to understand
and that's why in the book
there is another title
which is about globalization.
Once you have globalization
and the way we have a globalization
meaning that you take
a product or service,
you basically now defragment
it to several stages
in each country or place in the
world now does those things.
So let's think about
the semiconductor industry for a moment.
The US has a beautiful one.
Israel has a great one.
Taiwan has a great one.
Korea has a great one.
And yet in those places
some of the same companies
working all those places but what they do
in those places are completely different.
So in Silicon Valley and in Israel,
they try to put new ideas on silicon.
But they, as we now know thanks to Intel
and what happened in the United States,
without the Taiwanese company called TSMC,
we no longer know how to
put those ideas on silicon.
And that's where Taiwan excels.
In Korea, when you buy any
mobile phone, including an Apple,
the second highest amount of
profit now occurs to Samsung
which control critical things
that go to every smartphone on earth.
That also tells you where you have, say,
power over the network.
And let me just in this small examples,
Taiwan and Korea might
have actually more power
on the whole network on the mobile phones
than Silicon Valley right now.
The second is those different
kinds of innovation,
let us say different
skills, different finance,
provide to the community
completely different
kinds of employment.
So you mentioned Israel,
which is a small country
and everybody thinks is
a great economic miracle,
versus Taiwan, let's say, or Finland.
Unfortunately, as somebody who has done
a lot of research on all
but also grew up in Israel,
what happened in Israel because Israel
imitate Silicon Valley, might
be the only case of a place
which actually managed to
imitate Silicon Valley fully.
Israel is now one of the most,
just like Silicon Valley,
one of most unequal places on earth.
As a matter of fact, in the same year
as you have this massive economic miracle,
the Israeli society went that way.
And right now, one out of
every five household in Israel
is under the poverty line
and basically on a treadmill to nowhere.
While only the graduates
of the best universities,
best technological units, the financier,
and celebrity chefs, are enjoying
high-end Silicon Valley wages
and the lottery ticket called, you know,
stock options for an IPO.
So I think one of the real
questions that real places
should have is why do you
want to have innovation?
Why spend taxpayers' money on innovation
if you're a small city?
And if the reason is I
want to create prosperity
for my citizen, my residents,
imitating Silicon Valley,
even if you can be successful,
might be wrong answer.
- We saw a good example of
what we were describing with.
Semiconductors with US auto makers
where they're having to slow
or stop production for trucks
because of the lack of access to chips
from Taiwan at the moment.
So these global production
networks are hugely important.
Okay, so Israel is a case of
replication without the gains.
Let's think more about how
innovation could be pursued
and the gains can be more widely shared.
So one of the messages
I took from your book
was don't try to emulate these,
you know, canonical places.
But then I'm sure people want to know
what dreams should Cleveland, Ohio have?
Brampton, Ontario or Birmingham, UK,
what can be the ways they
pursue innovation policies
in the context of old industries?
Let us say.
- So first, let's talk
about an old industry.
And let me give an example of one
of the oldest industries in the world.
Shoes.
You know, the things you put on your foot.
(Woody laughs)
And let's talk about
high-end luxury woman shoes.
And once you look at that industry,
which by the way create
a lot of prosperity,
you found out that one of the places
which has the highest and
the most sustained prosperity
for people who not just
designer from, you know,
the top-end schools,
is Riviera del Brenta,
in Italy, just about Venice.
And the reason is that they focus
on what I call the second
stage of innovation.
So if you are a wonderful
designer from Milan,
or Paris, or New York, and
you design a really cool shoe
and you say, "Okay, now
this shoe has to be made.
"I have to be able to sell
it for an X amount of price.
"And a real human being
has to wear that shoes.
"And if that really human
being is paying 2000 euros,
"they might actually want to
walk on it from time to time.
"So it can not just explode."
The place that will make
that happen for you is Brenta
and its set of suppliers,
very high-end suppliers,
very high-end.
If you want to think about
it designing of how you make
an idea into a product,
running up into production,
very high-end production,
selling it to you.
And by the way, Woody, if
you're not creative enough
this year and you had
only a hundred new shoes
and you need 200, you can
also get the Brenta people
to come up with another hundred.
And that's very wide prosperity
for people from those
who can actually design
shoes, the creative,
to the people who know
how to put, you know,
the sole to the end of a shoe and sell it.
- Sounds like a story of
the rediscovery of craft.
And then one way, you
know, that rediscovery
is a form of invention taking
something that's been around
for a long time, applying
it to new settings,
paying attention to skill
so that more and more people
are involved in learning that skill.
Is there a difference in
our educational systems
between places that
focus more on, you know,
high-end computer science and finance
versus those that are
more skilled (indistinct)?
- To a agree, yes.
And definitely in the case of Brenta.
But if I go to Taiwan,
since we mentioned it again,
Taiwan is also known for,
I don't know if you ride
bikes, but if you ride bikes
especially--
- I'll buy one.
(Woody laughs)
- Especially if you move to
mountain bikes a few years ago,
by definition, you had a Taiwanese product
mostly almost surely from Giant.
And what you see in Taiwan is, again,
they took a very old product
basically it's a diamond frame
designed 200, 300 years ago,
and infuse it with new technologies,
in that case, new materials.
So you can make the bike go on off-road.
It was light enough for people
who are not looking like
you know, Superman to actually carry it
into the mountain and
start mountain biking.
What is interesting here and
the reason I wanted to say,
you need extremely
high-end material science
in order to do that.
But you also need the people who produces.
That means that while you have
a very high-end universities
and almost fundamental research
and researchers in Taiwan,
what they do in Taiwan,
how they use those skills
and the incentives that they get
in order to use those skills,
finance and other are different.
So again, depending on your stage
and depending how you attack it
and depending if you're
Cleveland and you have
an amazing university and
an amazing health system,
or if you're Hamilton,
Ontario, and you have the same,
or you're in a place
which closer to Brenta,
if you want to think about,
and you still have those craft
skills, as you call them,
design a strategy around that.
Design a strategy around a
different stage of production.
Do not assume that if you
don't become New York,
Silicon Valley, or Tel Aviv,
you cannot innovate and gain prosperity.
And unfortunately, as
we have talked before,
that conversation no longer
exist with policymakers.
They all think that if they are not
Silicon Valley of the North,
you know, I'm in Canada
so at least 15 cities claim that title,
we are not innovative.
And I think it's a misservice
to our own residents to think that way.
- It's a really important insight.
I take from it a couple of things.
One, through all the stories
in your wonderful book,
there is this focus on continuous updating
whether it's bicycles or shoes.
You know, so there's a drive
to constantly make these things better
And better doesn't involve disruption,
often involves making things better
so the consumers will,
you know, like them more,
they'll be lighter,
they'll be more durable.
There are a lot of positives
for many people in that.
You use the word incentives.
Okay, we typically think of incentives
as tax breaks, government funding.
I don't think those are the kinds
of incentives you mean though?
- I will say, let's be very
clear, some of them are.
Okay, there's a lot of
role for government.
And much of a role for government
especially with innovation which is risk,
is indeed with creating those incentives
that you just talked about.
But the other set of
incentives, and again,
it's a public private policy,
is a vision of how you want your society,
a vision of status and what
those people want to have.
But also a set of regulations
that allow or disallow
different kinds of business models
even if a lower short term profit.
Which I think is really
important right now
speaking about
semiconductors manufacturing.
Intel, it may be one last American company
that can announce whether
it is investing $20 billion
in having fabrication
or manufacturing sites
for semiconductors without
the CEO being fired
within five minutes by
Wall Street analysts
and their friends.
And those are the kinds of incentives
which we don't talk about
in a polite company.
But I think with, especially
in North America, we should.
- I hear you doing two
things with that statement.
One, telling us important lesson
which is that we should care
as much about the person
who builds the bike, the
person who crafts the shoes,
the person who bravely
makes a decision to invest
in a new fab plant, as
we should, you know,
the 26 year old, Vinder Ken,
who comes up with, you know,
the new way to take a vacation
or to have food delivery.
So that's a rethinking of who
the stars of innovation are.
There's also lots of discussion
though about innovation
as something that leads
to gains for only a few.
And I think that's, well I
will turn to the audience now
and Rachel you're in charge of that,
to help us think more broadly
about what are ways to make
innovation more inclusive.
- Before we turn to the audience,
and I have a question
that I wanted to ask for.
Do you want to respond to Dan or.
- Sure, so let me just be very clear
of that's exactly the reason why we,
and when I say we I mean you, I, Rachel,
and another 12 people, have
created a new CIFAR programme
which is called Innovation, Equity,
and the Future of Prosperity.
And it's exactly that fear that we have
or that many have that innovation,
at least in last 20
years, means that the few
and as Woody has very politely said,
the few who are 26 year old,
and the graduate of Stanford,
Berkeley, and the UFT,
so not exactly the people
we should worry about,
have all the gains and the rest
of the population does not.
And what we're doing in the network
and what we are thinking about
is actually figuring out
whether it's true or not.
And I think it's clearly not.
And then wondering how what
would be called the incentives
or what other people might call it
different innovation policies,
lead different places, countries
down at different trajectories
of how they innovate
and how the gains of
innovation are distributed
for other societies and for whom.
And that's exactly the
discussion we're starting
at CIFAR across multiple disciplines.
- So the question that I have for you both
is in some ways a followup
to that and kind of thinking
through different types of innovation
although potentially
with a different meaning.
So everyone seems to be putting
their favourite adjective
in front of the word innovation
whether it's social innovation,
frugal innovation, inclusive innovation.
And so I'm curious to hear your thoughts.
First, are these important
or necessary distinctions
to make and if they are, why?
- I'll start and Dan can pick up.
I think at one level all of these are ways
of trying to soften or appropriate
the term innovation or transform it
so that the element of it that has to do
with novelty and invention is retained
but you shift the discussion
to ask innovation for whom?
And I think it's that for
whom that is now a new framing
that is necessary in order
to get people to think
differently about the
gains from innovation.
- I agree.
I mean, my fear
is that soon and since we're all
sort of sociopolitical
economists in this panel,
that soon if we will continue
to have social innovation,
inclusive innovation, innovation
will end up like culture
meaning it is encompassing everything
and has zero meaning by itself.
And I'm very worried about that.
So I would say the good thing about it,
those hyphen of innovation
is that it shows
that people realise how
important innovation is
to their welfare and to their society.
Indeed, we will all be stuck
in a room without innovation,
all kinds of innovation,
but people who came with the vaccines
and as we in Canada knows
that people who actually
know how to produce the
vaccines are equally important.
But I'm worried that those
hyphenated innovation
has now moving the
debate slightly offside.
And we are not asking the
really important question
about innovation, growth,
equity, and prosperity anymore.
- There's a question from the audience
that's kind of bringing
us back in some ways
to where we started in talking
about kind of place-based innovation.
And in this case it's specifically
coming from Alberta, Canada,
where the kind of
innovation in the economy
has really been dominated
by fossil fuels in the energy sector.
Although, arguably now,
there seems to be a shift
to some degree to become, you
know, some version (laughs)
as you pointed out Silicon
Valley of the North
with the tech driven focus around AI
and whether or not an approach
like that makes sense.
Again, I think the important part here
is given Alberta centrality around,
you know, fossil fuels and energy.
- So I'll start and Woody you can chip in.
What is interesting for me about Canada,
speaking about fossil,
it's that there's actually two provinces
for playing this game as we speak.
One is Alberta and the
other is Newfoundland.
And they have both chosen
completely different
strategies in the past.
And then we have another
case which I'm really fond of
that I think Woody might know even more
of a small country called Norway.
- Yeah, I think I have.
- That also has
lack of the same problem.
So if you look across those cases,
I think what is interesting
in the two cases
that I am slightly more inclined to say
have chosen smart based on what they have
is actually, might be
Newfoundland and Norway.
Because what they have done is realise
what kind of skills they already have
in around that industry.
So it's not just AI, it's AI for mining.
It's how to deal with ice.
It's moving to what
people call green tech.
So you take your skills of knowledge
and you try to diversify
to related industries
or thinking about leap frogging
but from the knowledge we already have.
The other thing which
I think is as important
is let's assume for the moment
that Alberta actually
becomes Silicon Valley.
What happens to all those people
who now works in the
industry at the moment.
And the problem of trying to imitate
and move to Silicon Valley,
even if it's successful to
one or two of Alberta cities,
is that it does not solve
the real looming problem.
And that is that Alberta was the engine
of an unbelievable amount
of really good jobs
for upper middle class
people who are not graduates
of the best engineering
schools for all of Canada.
This is unfortunately
coming to an end, I fear.
And it's not just a problem for Alberta
but it's a problem for all of Canada
is to figure out what kind of jobs
or what kind of innovation
strategy we can have
that actually supplies
good jobs for those people.
Maybe thinking like North Carolina
instead of thinking like
Silicon Valley might be the way.
But Woody, what do you think
about Norway as a model?
- Well, I was, as you started
talking, I was thinking Norway
would be an interesting
example for Alberta
where they take the endowments
in the ground, under the sea,
in the skills and use those
endowments to make a transfer
into new industries,
make investments in them.
But I think maybe the
harder issue is not like
what do we do on the ground
but what goes on in people's minds.
So in a place like Alberta, Texas,
lots of places where
people have prosperity
from old ways of doing things,
change and doing something differently
is often seen as a threat,
as a huge challenge,
they're trying to take
away what we've done.
But a different way to think
about innovation is not just
that it's created by outsiders,
but maybe insiders want to change the way
they're doing things in
order to remain on top.
There's a great Italian
novel, "Lampedusa",
about if you want things to stay the same,
you have to change.
Is the theme from that.
And we know Alberta, at the
moment, has the prosperity
that could be used to see
beyond the world of fossil fuels
whether they have the mindset do that
is, of course, a very different question.
- We have time for one or
two more quick questions
and there's some great ones coming in.
So what is the role of
corporate governance
is really kind of at
the heart of the issues
that you're talking about,
the distribution of power
in the corporation, who
makes the decisions,
who distributes the profit to whom.
What corporate governance systems
work better for innovation?
Is this something that's
internal to the firm
or is regulation from state required?
- So Woody, do you want to be first or?
- Ah, yeah, I guess
you want me to go first
'cause that's one, such a
phenomenally good question
and two, such an incredibly hard question.
Okay.
And
clearly the model of how
boards ought to operate
or could operate in the context
of entrepreneurial innovation
has been a huge challenge.
Because the people are running the boards
have either been the VCs
who backed the companies or the founders
often with special
shares that allowed them
to have enormous influence for
a continuing period of time.
And thinking about novelty, and invention,
and corporate governance, I
think this is as important
as thinking about product innovation.
So in one sense, I'm punting
to say there's not enough work
being done on figuring out
different models of governance
that might have a longer time horizon
and also think more broadly about
who the beneficiaries of companies are.
There's some examples.
They're often in somewhat exotic places
but now there are companies
turning to be B Corporations.
For example, let's say we have
both financial and social goals.
There are others that
have tried to bring in
stay cut different stakeholders.
But we need fresh thought
about innovation and
corporate governance, I think.
Dan.
- So I'll just add that
it's not just the corporate.
Just look at what happened to Boeing
and then start to think why it happened.
And it happened because we also change
what are the legal requirement
from a CEO, a CFO, to the shareholders.
And the end result is Boeing,
a company which actually makes
a lot of its money on defense
catering more to short-termism
on Wall Street and making decision
where to allocate R and D funds
on changing body frames of
aeroplanes  but ended up
with a completely unnecessary
disaster like for Max.
Partly because it was
decision we're taking 15 years
before saying we are not
allowed, legally allowed,
to make those massive investment
in the long-term R and D
because the CEO would lose his job
and the real job that I have
now, corporate governance,
is to make shareholders
happy now and always now.
And that's a big issue that
I think we have to tackle
but I think we're running
out of time in this session.
- In fact, that is all
we have time for today.
I'd like to thank you both for joining us.
I'd especially like to thank
all of you for joining us
and I'd especially like
to thank Dan and Woody
for sharing your insights with us.
Please visit cifar.ca to find
out more about this series,
to view recordings of
this and other talks.
And the recording from this
talk will be up next week.
Thanks everyone, so long.
- Thank you, bye.
- Thank you for the wonderful
comments in the chat.
(upbeat music)